perche aux halles allait bientôt faire
ses premiers pas d'actrice à la télé
elle est au casting du téléfilm meurtre
à omaha beach
on voit que à gâteau prouve qu'avec
beaucoup elle découvre les infos dans ce
sera diffusé sur france 3 elle jouera
aux côtés de claire borotra michel
jonasz ou encore jean françois balmer
alors cherché à zale actrice que vous y
croyez ou pas mais trouve que c'est une
reconversion assez étonnante
mais pour elle m'étonne à la télévision
ça sur corner a été habitué par les
animateurs télé dechavanne boccolini
reichmann qui sont passés de l'animation
à la fiction
là c'est la première fois qu'une
présentatrice de jt boîtes noires se
mettre à l avance de sur le devant de la
scène
vous aviez dit roman prenant là c'est
totalement ridicule et c'est aussi
ridicule que la et et michel cymes dans
la mersey sinon il a fait plus de 6
millions de t shirt toute la série
cartonne
non non il a plus qu'à retenez que les
bains il était nul franchement ça aurait
dit que c'est laisse moi finir qui l'a
même pas vu mais tu n'as pas vu je vais
oublier ces petits mais je les veux que
tu restes ici
non mais las casas tu n'as pas vu le
dire il sera ré bien que leur art
édicules qu'est ce que t'en sais c'est
une manie c'est comme la pièce que t'as
pas vu c'est comme le bouquin ne t'a pas
lui c'est comme une drogue que t'as pas
vu tu es le seul journaliste au monde
qui sait à l'avancé que les choses sont
nuls sans les avoir vus ou l'âme
[Applaudissements]
écoutez tout et ja scoop qui vient de
tomber
qui après trois ans on a trouvé sa place
à trouver sa bonne place
c'est là ça rentre du beau papier collé
l'obi 1 oui mais ils ont clamé m tu as
raison gilles tu croises own les gens
bien sûr il mais s'il est excellent il
était le seul à finir tu n'aimes pas
mais il était très bon on est claire
chazal par ll est excellente au théâtre
par exemple elle a déjà foulé les scènes
de théâtre je trouve qu'elle a une
sensibilité elle a un regard et la boue
vraiment apporter quelque chose